welcome back i keep rushing to try to
get under the wire for these problems
but uh let me explain it properly
so what we did is we said that a new
student joins and the average after he
joins is equal to the median and what we
did is we figured out what's the average
in the median before the student joins
well the average before the student
joined was 13 over 12 and the median
before the student joined
was one
if the new student has one or zero
and what we we established the only way
to bring this average down is for the
new student to have uh
well less than the average number
of siblings right that's the only way we
can go from 1 1 1 12
to 1.
and i'll tell you right now that
he's actually going to he's actually
going to have a 1 13 impact right if
he's one away
so it actually you know i can tell you
right now he has he has one sibling but
i'll show it to you mathematically if
you don't have that intuition on
averages but the important thing to
realize is that he's either going to
have zero or one sibling or he's gonna
have he's gonna have to have less than
one and one twelve siblings so it's
either zero or one in order to bring the
average down
and regardless of whether he has zero or
one sibling the median won't change i
mean you could if he has one sibling
then we're just gonna have another one
here and then this will become the
median if he has zero siblings then
that's going to be a 0 there but that's
still going to be a median of 1. so the
median is not going to change
so what we have to do is we have to
figure out how many siblings does he
have to have for the new average to be
exactly 1.
so we can go back to this calculation
let's take the average but now let's
take it with him
so this was our our previous average
where we said well there's three
students with zero siblings six students
with one etcetera etcetera but now we're
going to add this new student in
there's one student with ex siblings
right
and then instead of a 12 in the
denominator we now have 13 because we
now have 13 students right
so what happens you essentially have 13
so this becomes x plus 6 plus 4 plus 3
this
becomes 13 plus x and then the
denominator
is equal to 13.
and actually i was wrong before he's
actually going to have to have zeros
dude so my intuition was a little bit
off
because look this is the new average 13
plus x over 13. the new average is going
to be 13 plus x
over
right
13 plus x over 13. and what does that
new average have to equal it has to
equal
one
because that's the new median or the old
median because we said the median
doesn't change so how can 13 plus x over
13 equal to one well if it doesn't make
if you can't eyeball that because you
could just say 13 plus x multiply both
sides by 13 is equal to 13.
and then subtract x from the x subtract
13 from both sides and you get x is
equal to zero
so that new student has zero siblings
i know that was a little bit convoluted
so let me just tell you what i did again
i said
what is the current median and i just
listed out all of the number of siblings
and i took the middle number and that
was one then i said well what is the
current average and the current average
was 1 and 1 12. i and this might confuse
a little bit you could just say well
this is the same thing as 0
sorry 0 plus 0 plus 0 plus 1 plus 1 plus
1 plus 1 plus
1 plus 1 and so forth instead i said
that's 3 students with 0 6 students with
1 sibling 2 students with 2 siblings and
so forth and i figured out that the
current average and i divided by 12 was
1 to 1 12.
so i said well no matter how many
siblings the next student has and
actually didn't even matter if even if
he had more or less that one of the
middle numbers still would have been the
one so the median will not change
regardless of where the new student
falls into the mix so we said how many
siblings does that
student need to have for the average to
come down back to 1
and then i just added x to my previous
average and i divided by 13 instead
because now i have an extra student this
was a 13 2
and we got this equation 13 plus x over
13 has to equal my new average which is
one
and then i solved for x which is zero so
the new student had zero siblings
next problem
and the really fast way of doing this
not to harp on this problem too much is
to and i should have done this from the
beginning is to figure out that the
median is one
then figure out that it doesn't matter
you know how many siblings the student
has the median is still going to be one
you can insert a number anywhere in this
list and the median would have still
been one because there's so many
students with one sibling
and then you just have to figure out
well how many students
how many siblings does this student have
to have for the average to become one
that's probably the most convoluted
explanation i've given but let me just
hope it helps you
okay
problem number nine
if two
two times x minus three is equal to
eight
what does
x minus three over x plus three
equal
what does that equal
well a couple of things let's see let's
just solve for x
so we get x minus 3 is equal to i'm just
going to divide the numerator and then
i'm just going to divide both sides by
2. so 8 divided by 2 is 4
right 2 divided by 2 is 1 so you get x
minus 3 equals 4 x is equal to 7. so you
go here what's x minus 3 well that's 7
minus 3 which is 4.
we also figured out that x minus 3 was 4
up here
and then what's x plus 3 that's 7 plus 3
so that's 10.
4 tenths we can reduce that to 2 fifths
dividing the numerator and the
denominator by 2 so that's our answer
two-fifths or 0.4
problem 10.
when twice a number so whenever i start
i just start writing it let's say x is a
number so they say when twice an hour so
when 2 times x that's twice a number
is decreased by 3. so twice a number is
decreased by three as twice numbers
decreased by three the result is 253 so
the result equal sign is 253.
what is a number well i while reading it
i set it up so now we just have to solve
so we add 3 to both sides 2x is equal to
right i added 3 to both sides
x divide 2
both sides by 2 x is equal to 128
and we are done
next problem
problem 10
okay this says outdoor sneaker companies
july production
so we have white
black and then total
total and then they have high tops
low tops
and then total
and i don't know if people even wear
high tops anymore
i used to
i guess for basketball
okay high tops low tops and then total
i'm very not plugged in
high tops low tops
and then total and what numbers do they
have in the box
in the box so there are 3 600 here
1500 here
and then 10 000.
so i can even before reading this
question i can tell you're just going to
want us to fill in
this diagram 10 000 here
outdoor sneaker company manufactures
only white sneakers and black sneakers
both of which are available as either
high tops or low tops on the basis of
the information in the table above how
many black sneakers
did outdoor sneaker company manufacturer
in july so how many black sneakers so
they didn't differentiate with high tops
or low tops so they want to know how
many total black sneakers so that is
black total so we need to figure out
this square
total black so let's see what we can
figure out i'll do my figuring out in
this magenta
so if low tops i need a total of 5500
low tops 1500 are black how many are how
many are white
well it's going to be four thousand
right i just took fifty five hundred
minus fifteen hundred four thousand
similarly if i made a total of ten
thousand speakers and fifty five hundred
of our low tops
how many of them are high tops well this
is going to be ten thousand minus fifty
five hundred
so this is forty five hundred
and then out of the high tops
if thirty six hundred are white and i
made a total of forty five hundred how
many black are there well 4 500 total
minus the white ones
that's what that's 900
and so if we want to figure out the
total black we now know how many high
top blacks there are and how many low
top black sneakers there are so we just
add so 900 plus 1500 is 2400
so i actually wasted both of our times
figuring this out so i could have saved
a few seconds if i didn't do that but i
was just mindlessly chugging along
anyway i'll see you in the next video